i think that we need today
to follow faith and reason
and not only philosophical reasons but
also scientific reason and put together
in a real dialogue these things like do
pope francis in laudato si
that describe the situation of the world
especially the question on climate
change
and put this in relation of our
tasks in the world uh in uh
that come from the scriptures that we
are the stigmas of
of the earth there we don't say creation
because
too much but there and and for this we
need
faith reason philosophication
values moral reason and scientific
reason
so in understanding how we change the
world
in order to achieve goals that we can
defend and i agree there can be
but there isn't necessarily overlap
between the goals of
say secular humanism and a religious
worldview but to the extent that we
uh agree if we agree that those goals
are human flourishing
namely life health education happiness
richness of experience
then how we maximize those is going to
very much depend on our understanding of
what causes what in the world and our
understanding of what causes what in the
world
comes from science by definition because
that's what science is in the business
of doing
namely understanding the world with the
unders with
the method that none of us is omniscient
that we cannot understand the world by
revelation
by faith by dogma by sacred texts
but rather by proposing hypotheses
and seeing letting the world tell us
whether they are
true or false the fact that we
can see ways in which we've improved the
world by the application of knowledge
emboldens us to think that we can
improve it still further but
[Applause]
for the visible war i completely agree
but they are
another part of the world that we can
say invisible war
that is not enough science we need
for this for the great meanings
we need something that comes from
revelation
why should we believe revelation well
revelation to
to put in relation with faith revelation
with that is to say some new
intervention in the world that is not
the only declaration but is a new
intervention
of god in the world but if it's
revelation
it has not been revealed to me maybe
it's been revealed to you
what are you going to do about the fact
that there are people like me
people in this audience people in the
world who um
have not seen the same revelation that
you may have seen
who have no plans to accept jesus as our
savior
i am a jew i'm i'm going to tell you i'm
not going to accept jesus sorry
i don't think i'm i don't think i'm
that's a big problem in terms of making
the world a better place
i don't think that the billions of
people who have not and will not accept
jesus
i don't think that's the world's problem
uh they have not
experienced the same revelation perhaps
that you have i don't think that's the
problem either because we don't need
revelation if we can appeal to
dimensions of experience that are
available to everyone
such as evidence such as reason such as
a concern with human flourishing